we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
here's a voicemail from a conspiracy
theorist who goes by the name total
control this is an exercise in caution
this is what can happen when your brain
is on conspiracy theories
no it's been a while right I didn't want
all of 2022 to slip by without you
knowing that I'm still alive I know I
know you're just killing yourself right
now right
but I I still have the same question I
think the last time I called and put on
your voicemail
why am I still alive
I never take a single injection I never
use a face diaper I never socially
distance and yet I keep on living just
fine
not even a head cold wow
and nobody around me is getting sick
either
so hey Dave I'm just calling to find out
how come well I guess this will make the
is this the Third
prediction of severe winter of illness
and death and were up to Triple demic
now right first it was twendemic now
it's triple democracy you know it's
interesting just speak it's sort of like
I don't know they keep talking about car
accidents but I've been driving for 20
years and I'm alive so there must really
be nobody dying in car accident it's
very very dumb What's it gonna be next
winter quadruple damic I don't know what
can I say
seems to me like nobody can ever keep it
straight because you know it's
um evolving with the rolling of the eyes
but anyway I'm still here I'm still
kicking all right well total control
hasn't died and he wants us to know that
despite uh despite not being vaccinated
and of course that is the very very
scary Mind of a conspiracy theorist for
lack of a better term we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah we're going
to make money on the bonus show today
with the following topics we are going
to talk about House Republicans taking
as one of their first actions yesterday
removing the metal detectors from the
house floor okay we'll talk about what
they're doing tobacco companies in Spain
are being billed for the cleanup of
cigarette butts this is very interesting
and we will also talk about the number
of children in the United States who
accidentally ate cannabis Edibles in
2021 and does this vindicate the claims
of the anti-cannabis right wing
and it does not we will talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get access instantly not in
an hour not in a day get access
instantly by signing up at
joinpakman.com